on the left a former student protest
leader who in february turned 35 the
minimum age for running for president
why did we become used to so much
inequality why did we allow it to grow
before our eyes never again we will
change it
on the far right a second generation
german immigrant who supported chile's
former military dictatorship and
believes that there is a global
left-wing conspiracy
chile will never be a marxist or
communist country because we believe in
freedom
this is gabriel borich when he became a
congressman seven years ago for the
newly formed left-wing political
coalition that pushed for structural
social reforms
he represents a new generation that took
to the streets two years ago demanding
more equality in chile which has one of
the highest income inequalities in the
world his symbol is this tree from where
he used to imagine a better future for
chile from his home city of puntarenas
that overlooks the strait of magellan
agatha a single mother tells us she's
not worried about his youth
no i feel that's what we need a new
vision new ideas more support for young
people to get ahead
but some moderates and investors are
frightened of bodhichi's alliance with
the communist party
boris has changed his style to look a
bit more presidential and has been
recalibrating his program to reach out
to those who still see him as too
radical but he's not the only one who
has been significantly tweaking his
profile
former congressman cast is an old school
ultra-conservative catholic who opposes
abortion and same-sex marriage his motto
is make chili great again
he would expel undocumented migrants and
his position on climate change is
lukewarm
he would maintain chile's unbridled free
market model and lower taxes for big
business
but in recent weeks he's reconsidered
allowing the military to make arrests
without a warrant during a state of
emergency
cast's biggest drawing card is his
promise to restore law and order
what chilemos needs is security this was
a peaceful country where anyone could
walk around any hour now it's not safe
anywhere
cast represents the return of public
order and respect for authorities
bordich the hope that dreams of social
justice can come true
two different models confront each other
in this election two generations with
opposing visions of what chile needs two
different ways of seeing life as well
will we face convulsive times yes
either one could become the next
president of a country that has lost its
political center the very thing that for
three decades seemed to guarantee
chile's reputation as latin america
standard bearer of political and
economic stability lucia newman al
jazeera santiago